[音楽]
ブードゥー君
r
a
うーん
ああああああうーん
ああああああああ
わー
うーんうーん
ああああああ
[音楽]
皆さんこの状況をどんな状況かわかりますか
何をしても一向に泣きやまない赤ちゃんの泣き声です
24時間365日はが固有性の生活です
おむつかな
お乳かな
お熱かな
何をしても泣きやまない我が子です
外出は公園とスーパー
会話するのは近所の人かパートナーか
ごく限られた人たちです
自分自身もめいいっぱいになってちょっと助けてっていう声さえ
あげれない状況でした
自分だけが社会から取り残されているような感覚に陥る
こんな毎日がいつまで続くんだろう
そこまでだったらいいんですけどママって誰かのせいにし出すんですね
旦那のせいダートか
近所の人のせいやなんで私ばっかり言ってこういう状況です
これが本当にままの置かれている現状ではないでしょうか
私の独身時代と
子供を産んでからの24時間表です
比べてみると本当に自分の時間というのはほとんどありません
出産後ですが見てください
23時間毎の授乳
小刻みの睡眠時間
24時間それを繰り返します
その時に赤ちゃんが寝ないときがあるのでずっと横だけで私も長男
ね目の前にいるんですけど超なおこうやって横だけにしたいった時に腱鞘炎になって
しまってテーピングを張って痛いのになおらーないままにまた抱っこするみたいな生活
を繰り返ししていました
その間に寝たなぁと思って寝かしつけておいて火事しようかなと思ったらまた起きて
しまう
夜まで経っても寧夏路が終わらないっていうような状況でそれを言い訳に
仕事から帰ってきた旦那さんに
ごめん子供が全然言うこと聞いてくれへんかって言ってまた人のせいにするっていう
ような生活です
そんな忙しい毎日がずっと続くんです
でも
ママたちは社会とつながりたい
社会の役に立ちたいってずっと思っているんです
現在
日本では出産を機に仕事を辞めてしまう女性が6割以上いるといわれています
でもママたちは働けん内ではなく働かないという選択をしていることに気づいているん
ですね
で働かない理由が3つあります
まず一つ目は
可愛い盛りの我が子を預けてまでも働きたくないという理由です
私も今2歳の子供がいるんですけど本当に0歳から3歳までの可愛い盛りっていうのは
子育ててほんと期間限定だって
子育て終わった大先輩からよく言われたりするんですけども
この子の成長今この側で見ておきたいなっていうのが親の願いではないでしょうか
二つ目の理由が
保育園料や病気のことで立場的に不利になるということです
時給と補遺経理を払ったらバランスが悪くなってしまって
ママってよく何のために働いてるんやろうって
時短でしか働けなくなってしまうんですね
じゃそんな時にせっかく働いたのに病気や発熱とかで緊急事態で呼ばれることがあり
ます
緊急事態で呼び出しが来たらなんか職場の人たちすいません
子供の保育園から急に熱が出たって言ってるので迎えに行かないといけませんって
申し訳ないですっていう風な形で職場の人にこうやって頭を下げないといけません
そうなってきたらなんか周りの人に迷惑かけるにあったら私が今子供保育園に預けずに
自分で見てその方が迷惑かからへんしその方がいいんちゃうかなっていう選択をして
いるお母さん多いと思います
3つ目が夫の扶養の範囲内で働きたいという声も本当によく効きます
私もいろいろ働き方を模索してきました
長男が1歳7ヶ月の時にフィットネスのインストラクターという資格をとってその仕事
につきました
で最初は本当に子連れで手を引いて
そこそこ楽しくやっていたんですけど急に本当にその仕事の
もっともっと深めたいなぁと思い出して子どもを預けて
フィットネスクラブに働くようになりました
で実際に子供を預けて働いてみたんですけど本当に急な呼び出しあったりとか
もう10時から4時ぐらいまでしか働けないとか
上の子ができたらもう
3時には幼稚園ゴム海外からそこに戻らないといけないっていうような形で子育てと
仕事のバランスっていうのが本当に上手く撮れなかったです
でそれを妊娠を機にその仕事もへとやめました
で妊娠してもう働き続ける形はないかなっていうふうにずっと模索をし始めました
でちょうど次女が産まれた時に a と出会ったのが
ママの働き方応援隊通称まま畑という
仕事でした
このまま畑は子育て中がメリットいいなら働き方をつくるというミッションを掲げてい
て私はそのワードにビビビッときました
これなら子供と一緒に働ける仕事を通して社会とつながれると思ったんですね
そのまま畑の取り組みの一つが赤ちゃん先生プロジェクトというものです
小学校から高齢者施設行政や企業に出向いてさまざまなプログラムを提供しています
例えば
高校大学では学生さんたちに結婚出産を含めたキャリアデザインというものを考えて
もらっています
そうしたら女子学生が言うんですね私はキャリアの邪魔になるので子供は産みませんっ
て言っていた女子大一学生が赤ちゃん先生受講後
あ結婚出産もありかも
なんだかそれらを含めてキャリアデザインも考えてみようと思いますって言われたりし
ます
あるとき男子学生は
僕は就職ば大企業しか考えていません
でもお母さんたちの話を聞いたときに地域の企業でもいいかなって
その方がパートナーと子育て手伝えたりするから楽にできるのかも
で
いう言葉をもらったりします
他にも
行政や企業に出向いたりもします
例えば商品開発やイベントの企画などを手伝いをしているんですけども
実際に現場に行くと子連れっていうのを本当に厳しくてどんな声が出てくるかっていう
と
これですね子連れで何ができる
母親は子育てに専念するものだろう
子供を犠牲にしてまでも働きたいの
子連れでなんて考えが甘いって言うような言葉を相手から言われることは本当に多々
ありました
社会の子連れに対する壁のあずさにぶち当たって
そのたびに凹み涙することが多々あります
まだまだもう子連れの人が働くっていうのは
あの周りに理解は低いだなっていうのを石井氏と感じています
そうは言ってもこのような取組をずっと6年間ぐらい続けてきて
まま本来の能力に気付き始めた企業さんとかも結構あります
男社会とは違う
物の見方をするママによっていろんなことが生まれているんですね
例えばイベントとかよく手伝ったりするんですけど
ママ達って一番消費者に近い存在と言われています
企業担当者の方からママたちに以前レクチャーを受けてそのままたちはその事前に
レクチャーを受けたことを消費者目線であの自分の言葉にしてお客様に伝えることが
できます
そうするとお客様もすごく安心してあーこれすごい良いものなんだって思ってくださっ
たりします
使い方の工夫までアドバ
s したりします
そういう働き方を見てると企業の担当者から山まっすぐちょっと家の色紙会社で働きに
来てくれへん
子供連れてきてもええから託児所ないけどみたいな言葉をよく言われたりします
で実際にイベント大手携わったまま
が本当に担当企業のところに本格的に就職することも出てきています
もう一つは実際にファミリー向けの商品を男性が企画していたりするのでここをママ
目線でアドバイスしたりもし
させていただいてますホームページだったりチラシだったりに反映できて反響が出
たっていう声もいただいたりもしています
実際にママと仕事をすることで当初のネガティブなイメージも払拭されて
ままの能力などを理解してくるくらいランドさんが増えてきています
行政や企業に出向くときはと名刺を持って自分の名前を名乗ったりします
ママになるとなんかマルマルちゃんのママ私はずっと13年間何がニックンのまま
なになにちゃんのママってこ事務用にいるのでずっと言われ続けました
でママって呼ばれていると本当に自分のアイデンティティを見失ってしまうんですね
でふと自分の名前呼ばれたときに何か振り向けないぐらい自分って何者なのかっていう
のを見失いがちになります
でこの木活動期に名刺を持たママたちが言うんです
久しぶりに自分の名前フルネームで名乗りました
いつぶりですかねぇっていうふうにあの喜んでいる姿を見るの私は本当にとっても好き
です
自分の
仕事となるとやっぱり自分自身の名前を名乗りながら仕事をしていくので自分自身の
アイデンティティというのが本当に戻ってくるんだっていうことを体感しています
この写真なんですけど何の時か分かります
契約書ベースで仕事をしているんですけど契約も自分で進めていくんですねままがー
で契約をまあ取り付けました
契約を取り付けたらうわよっしゃーってあでもめっちゃこれ責任重いや
いう風にいつもママたちから声が上がります
自分の中で仕事っていうのが自分ごとになって位置づけられてしっかりと自立していく
っていうところが私はそこがすごく大事だなと思っています
このように子育て真っ最中であるにも関らず
ママも仕事を通して成長できることができるのです
このような成長を流すために実はまま畑の中には
ポジションという考え方があります
私も順番にステップ1から踏んできたんですが
ステップが上がるにつれて人に会う数が全然違うんですね
で実は子育て真っ最中だと公園とか幼稚園ママ保育園ママっていう形で子育て中の
お母さんとのコミュニティはすごくあるんですけど全然違う
価値観の人たちと出会うことっていうのはまず
子育て中では難しいなぁと思っています
まあ本てさまざまな価値観の人と数多く出会うことによって私自身も本当に仕事を通し
て自分の成長を実感しています
ママは子育てについて社会の中や地域の中で解決していくべきことを
感覚を通し知っています例えばベビーカー押していて段差に気づいたりとか
ものを買っても使い勝手が悪いなと思ったらそれを工夫してどうやったら使い勝手が
良くなるかとか
っていうふうなことをいつも工夫を積み重ねた生活をしています
本当に子育て期間限定と言われてますが気付くことがすごく多いですね
私も子どもがいなければ気づかなかったことっていうのは
えっとこの39年生きてきて本当にたくさんあったなと今振り返るとよく思います
そうして気づいた地域や社会の課題をビジネスとして解決するママの社会起業家が増え
たら本当に世の中も変わると確信しています
今の状況を変えるのは一番の当事者であるママたちの幸や行動だ
鍵になると思っています
私はこの6年間でほんと子供連れながら北海道から沖縄まで全国を渡り歩きました
その中で子育て中のお母さん2000名ぐらいの方達のリアルな声を聞いてきました
社会とつながりたい
子供と一緒に何かしたい
誰かの役に立ちたいっていうやる気のあるママが本当に日本には山ほどいるんだなって
いうことを
なんかこのままこのままたちを眠らしているのはもったいなすぎるって
本当に心から思います
これは本当に日本にとっても大きな損失になるんじゃないかなって
実際私はもう私なんてって私なんかがあって毎日不安で自信がなかった
でもそんな自分だから伝えたいことがあります
自分自身の可能性に気づいて一歩を踏み出す勇気と行動が誰かの役に立つっていうこと
です
目の前の人を笑顔にできるということです
私自身本当に子連れだと働けないって思ってました
赤ちゃんの存在というのは
制限だと思ってました自分の時間もなくなるし
でもなんか制限されていたりちょっとした負荷がかかってる方が人がパフォーマンスが
上がるっていうことも体感しました
自信っていうのは本当に経験のなさなんだなっていうことも
自身で体感してきました
でも
皆さんに最後にメッセージを伝えたいと思います
制限されているって言うことは視点を変えれたら新たな価値になるのではないでしょう
か
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]